when I was young I went to a public high
school in New Jersey that was known for
the fact that they spent more money on
football helmets than they spent on
textbooks it's changed since then but I
didn't come up thinking I was going to
be a scientist I didn't build a robot
until I was 21 years old and I started
off thinking well first i thought i was
going to be a singing veterinarian that
was when I was three after that I wanted
to be a firefighter when I got to
college though I'd sort of decided that
I was going to study kids I wanted to be
a developmental psychologist because I
was fascinated by how it is the children
are able to learn and the amazing range
of things that we're able to do so
quickly as infants and so I didn't land
a graduate degree and I studied with
some wonderful people and I studied kids
and I was all set to go and do that and
then I met a guy who built robots and we
had a fantastic conversation that lasted
for five years and throughout that time
we talked about how we could possibly
build robots that were like kids that
could learn as fast as kids that could
do the kind of fantastic range of things
that kids could do and after that
five-year conversation I suddenly found
I was a computer scientist and I was
studying kids still but I was building
robots and that's what I do today so
today I'm going to talk about this range
of projects that we're working on right
now to try to build interesting
technology for kids
in the world of robotics we've had
assistive technology for about 40 years
and most of that has been in the form of
these physically assistive devices if
you have a stroke if you have damage to
your brain that makes it difficult for
you to walk one of the therapies that
you can use is this robot therapy where
they put you in this sort of almost
power suit like thing that helps you to
move your legs before you're actually
able to and these devices help people to
regain the ability to walk that's the
kind of assistive technology that we've
been building for years it helps you to
physically move through some kind of
therapy today though in the last four or
five years we've started talking about a
different kind of assistive technology
where we try to help people not
physically but socially and we build
robots that look very different they're
often cute and fuzzy and furry they're
designed for kids they're small and they
sit on a little table and rather than
helping you to physically move they try
to do the same thing that a good coach
or a good teacher will do that is they
try to motivate you they try to help
guide you toward a particular goal and
they try to entertain along the way
that's what I'm going to talk about
today so we'll go through a couple of
steps at the beginning how do you make a
robot social and why do we use robots
why not use something on a touchscreen a
virtual character and then I'll show you
some of the results that we get we've
done a lot of work with kids with autism
and we're working right now with first
graders and second graders and I'll show
you some of the work with that so the
first question is how do you make a
robot social
how do you get a robot to be something
that people want to talk to and interact
with aren't robots just dumb machines
and that turns out to be really easy
because we see the world as if it is
social I can show you this video that I
stole from my friend and colleague Brian
Scholl that's based on a 1944 psychology
experiment where you see these three
little triangles move around on the
screen and you have no trouble seeing
the story you know which two of them
were friends and you know who was the
bully and you know who got frustrated
and who was angry at the end and all
I've shown you our triangles moving
around on a screen when you look at the
world your first instinct is to
interpret it as if it is social we do
this with everything all right adults
fess up how many of you have secret
names for your cars yeah okay why do you
give your car a name it's not a person
we do this all the time it's natural for
us we do the same thing with robots and
so one of the things that we study is
what are the kinds of things that cue
people to do that what are the things
that trigger you to say this is a
something I can talk to something I can
interact with rather than this is a
refrigerator I wouldn't talk to my
refrigerator sometimes that comes from
very simple motion cues and i'm going to
show you first a study that was done by
a high school intern from amity saw a
bunch of amity people here working in my
lab over the summer and it used this
little yellow robot named keep on and
keep on can move around on the desk and
we made videos
of three key box and I'm going to ask
you to do the same thing that we asked
people in this study I'm going to ask
you which robot is the best dancer so a
B or C which one is the best dancer
all right who says a the one on this
side was the best answer nobody ever
likes a who says be the one in the
middle was the best answer most of you
how many say C was the best answer okay
what was the difference between them
what was the difference yep
yeah so one of them was completely in
sync with the music the one in the
middle one of them was completely out of
sync the one over here nobody liked him
and one of them was on the bead half the
time and in the offbeat half the time
whenever we ask this question the
universal response is the one in the
middle is the best dancer he keeps time
with the beat but when we asked the
question which one of them is the most
human-like dancer everyone says see
because C is the one that seems to make
a mistake and then correct itself you
guys want to do one more all right which
one's the best dancer a B or C
you like a All Right see
what
why
ok
before you answer my question do you see
how easy as it is to make something
social yeah it's actually really easy
just that motion can do it all right
which one is the best dancer who says a
who says be who says see now it's a
little more split the difference between
them is in the number of sort of dance
moves that they have a has a repertoire
of about five moves be has a repertoire
of about seven and see has a repertoire
of about ten and when we've asked
thousands of people this question and
most of them prefer be once they get too
much complexity people don't like it as
much
they like to see a little repetition in
their dance so we know that we can make
things look social just by the way they
move and we know we can get people to
respond to them but we have another way
of doing this as well we can do this
from a very high level very cognitive
kind of effect so in this experiment we
use this little humanoid it's about this
tall named nico we ask people to come in
and sit down in front of nico and play
rock paper scissors everybody knows how
to play rock paper scissors right yeah
ok Rochambeau rock paper scissors ok the
first group that we invited in they
played 20 minutes with the robot and the
robot played rock paper scissors and
every time it would look down and it
would say either I win or you win or we
tied and it was the world's most boring
experiment ever and at the end we had an
incredibly bored group of undergraduates
because 20 minutes of rock paper
scissors is incredibly boring now the
second group they came in and they
played 20 boring minutes and then
something interesting happened the robot
would throw a gesture would lose but it
would look down and it would say I win
and people treated it as if it were some
kind of broken toaster something
terrible had gone wrong and here's some
of their responses they were confused
they were surprised but the robot was
still a big toaster they didn't talk to
it they didn't want to engage it they
they were still bored it was unusual but
it was still boring the last group had
the most interesting time they played 20
mooring minutes and then the robot would
throw a gesture and lose and it would
look down and change its gesture and say
I win and now watch their responses yes
so now all of a sudden it wasn't a
toaster anymore now it was a dirty
rotten cheater we made them play 20 more
minutes after that the boring first
group played 20 minutes and they hated
us because it was still boring the
second group that treated it like a
broken toaster they played 20 more
minutes and it was still 20 boring
minutes and this last group played 20
minutes and they sat on their edge of
their seats and they watched to make
sure that that cheating robot didn't do
this thing again and they talked to it
they suddenly after 20 minutes with this
thing they started talking to it when
they talked to us later about it they
used active verbs rather than passive
verbs they anthropomorphize the robot
they talked about it as if it were a
person because of that one thing that it
did sometimes we can turn things into
social creatures just by these little
changes okay so that brings us to a
question we can make things social we
know we can get people to respond to
these robots as if they're people but
why do we use robots robots are really
tough why don't we use a nice character
on a screen we could put a little
virtual character on your phone or on an
iPad why don't we do that because the
robots are more expensive they're
difficult to produce it means we've got
to do maintenance on them they're
fragile they're easier to break they're
harder to customize why use a real robot
if I want to help kids learn why use a
real thing and the answer comes from two
different places the first part is we
know that that physical body matters
because it changes
how willing you are to listen to the
robot so here's a study we did we had
people come in and sit in my office and
we told them that they were going to do
some office tasks for us half of them
sat next to the real robot Niko the
robot you just saw and half of them sat
next to that same robot but on a big
flat screen TV doing a two-way video
conference in both cases they knew the
robot could see them and they can see
the robot the robot would follow them
around as they moved around would wave
to them when they walked in we asked
them to proof read a document and file
some stuff and a bunch of other stuff
that didn't matter and then we asked
them to do the important thing we said
we need you to put some books away in
the office the robot knows where the
books go and then the robot would point
to a pile of textbooks and point to a
location on a shelf and everybody was
willing to go and take the books and put
them on the shelf whether they sat next
to the real robot or the virtual robot
and then the robot did the one trick
question it pointed to this nice big
pile of textbooks and then it pointed to
the trash can
how many people were willing to take
this pile of textbooks off of my desk
and throw them in the trash can because
the robot said so would you do it it's
hard to know until you're really there
the people who sat next to the real
robot two-thirds of them the line in
blue two-thirds of them picked up the
books walked over to the trash can put
them in the trash can turned around like
nothing strange had happened and said
what's next only about eighteen percent
one in less than one in five people who
sat next to the robot on the screen
picked up the books and threw them away
they all knew what the robot wants it
they all picked up the books they all
walked over to the trash can they then
tried to negotiate with the robot are
you sure you want me to put these over
here and the robot just pointed to the
trash can some of them tried to be
sneaky they hid the books behind the
trash can or they balance the books on a
shelf near the trash can somebody pulled
the table over and put the books on the
table near the trash can one woman put
the books on the floor and put the trash
can on top of the books to see if she
can pull the robot
but they really didn't want to throw
away those books so why when they're
sitting next to the real robot did they
do this and the answer is that when
we're there in person were more
compelling we've known this in business
for hundreds of years if you want to
sell someone something you go and you
visit them in person that's why we had
door-to-door salesmen that's why even
today if you have a big business deal
you go and visit your client you don't
call them you don't skype with them
being there in person makes people more
willing to listen to you the second
answer is that we learn better in person
we tried to come up with a task that was
just purely cognitive is just about
thought power and so we gave people a
logic puzzle is a logic puzzle called
monograms and in this puzzle you have to
sort of start with a blank field and
then fill in some of the squares
according to a set of constraints on the
rose and a set of constraints on the
columns and so for example this bottom
row here says six and then one and in
the finished puzzle you have to have six
consecutive filled in squares and then
some number of blank squares and then
one filled in square by itself but you
have to do this so that it matches not
only the constraints here but also the
constraints on each of the columns now
for this bottom row it's easy there's
only one way I can put six and then a
space and then one in this row of eight
but for this first column I've got one
and then two and then one and so there's
a lot of different ways I can do that as
you learn to solve these puzzles there
are tricks that you learn for example I
can look at this and I can tell that
there's only one way to fill this in and
so regardless of what the columns say I
know exactly what that bottom row needs
to be I can then use that to start
figure
bring out other things so we asked
people to come in and and solve these
puzzles and we put them in five
different groups one group we said
you're on your own good luck here's four
puzzles go solve them we taught them the
rules we taught everybody the rules of
how to do them but then we said you're
on your own go ahead a second group sat
at the laptop solve these problems but
every once in a while they got a little
hint this voice would play from the
speakers on the laptop and would give
them a hint about how to solve these
puzzles the third fourth and fifth group
got those same hints but some of them
got them from a little video of the keep
on robot on their screen and some of
them got them from the real robot
sitting there next to the screen we gave
them four puzzles to solve only we
played a trick on them because we gave
them the first puzzle in the second
puzzle in the third puzzle and then for
the fourth puzzle we gave them the same
puzzle that they had on the first one
only we took it and we rotated it 90
degrees so nobody figured out that we
actually gave them the same puzzle but
it was the same puzzle so it was exactly
as hard and we did that so that we can
measure how much they had learned about
how to solve these puzzles and if you
solve these puzzles with no hints at all
you get better the first puzzle takes
you about 15 minutes to solve the fourth
puzzle takes you about 13 minutes to
solve if you get some of our hints if
you get them from the speaker's coming
out of the laptop where you get them
from the video of the robot your do
better the lessons help but if you get
those same lessons from the physical
robot sitting there next to you you
solve those puzzles about five minutes
faster now these people over here they
got the same information the same hence
the same lessons as these other folks
did
only they got it from someone in person
why do we respond like that why does
that physical presence being there make
us learn better we don't know exactly
why but it does this is why going to
class is a good idea when you're
physically there you learn more if
you're just watching it on a screen you
don't learn as much so go to class a
good thing the robots say so okay so I
want to be able to tell you a little bit
about what we do with this information
we know that we can build social robots
and we know that we can make those
robots compelling that is we can make
you do the things that the robots ask
and so we've been trying to put this to
good use our first set of projects dealt
with kids with autism autism is a
deficit the ten years ago when we
started this work I had to explain a lot
about what autism is no one knew what it
was the incidence rate was about one in
every 500 kids today the CDC says it's
one in 50 kids in the US will be
diagnosed with autism that's a 10-year
change a factor of 10 that's
unbelievable in a way now there's lots
of reasons that that's happened there's
been changes in the diagnostic criteria
changes and awareness but today almost
everybody has a sense of what autism is
it's a social deficit it's also a
deficit where we see a wide range of
abilities and it's something that there
is no cure for so we've been looking at
ways in which we can use these robots to
help kids with autism we do this because
there have been a whole wide variety of
robots worldwide from well let's see
everywhere from Canada to Japan
Switzerland Korea
the US the UK just about anywhere you
can think of roboticists have been
putting robots with kids with autism and
they've been seeing some phenomenal
things occur the first thing they see is
that the kids get highly motivated and
this is no surprise at all I gave a
child a cool new robot toy look they're
excited that's not news we also see that
the kids get this sort of long-term
engagement with the robot again I gave a
child who has a tendency to perseverate
on things who has a tendency to do the
same thing over and over again I gave
him a cool robot toy and he kept playing
with it for a long time that's not news
but what we sometimes see is we see
these kids suddenly start to display
social behavior that we don't typically
see them using when they're with the
robot rather than when they're with
people so we've been doing in
collaboration with the Yale Child Study
Center a number of long-term studies on
how robots can be useful in therapy and
we've been using this little dinosaur
robot called plio and plio was a
commercial product the company no longer
exists unfortunately but they were nice
enough to give us access to all the
internals so we reprogrammed them and we
were programmed them so that they could
respond to an infrared remote and so we
would secretly hit buttons on the remote
and the robot would do things and we
took the remote and we taped it to the
bottom of a clipboard and hid it and
we'd push button secretly to control the
robot and no one would ever tell that we
actually had this they all thought it
was coming directly from the robot and
so we took kids
nine to 12 year olds who were high
functioning these were kids who were
verbal they could talk but they had
clear social deficits and we tried to
engage in one of the standard therapies
that they do now a lot of these kids
have problems with what's called vocal
prosody and that's not the words you say
it's not what you say but it's how you
say it so we can tell tell the
difference between when I say you did a
great job and when I say you did a great
job and I said the same words but they
meant two different things that tone in
your voice has meaning and for many kids
with autism they have problems both
producing that kind of variation and
recognizing it and so we gave them what
is a standard therapy session for them
only rather than using a human with it
we use the robot we brought in the plio
robot we told them pleo is afraid of
water and we had the robot walk across
this little play mat and as the robot
walked across the playmat it would come
up to these rivers and when it got to
the river it would look down don't start
to shake and what sounds scared and the
child's job was to say something that
sounds encouraging they all knew the
right words to say you can do it play
out but a lot of them had trouble saying
it in a convincing tone of voice and so
they practiced this with the robot now
we did this with for them for only five
minutes with the kids so we weren't
really expecting them in five minutes to
suddenly be able to learn this skill but
what I want to show you is the change in
the children before they saw the robot
and after they saw the robot we talked
to them for a little while before they
saw the robot and after they saw the
robot and i'm going to show you one
typical eleven-year-old
rather typical for this study he's a
child who has real difficulties so
you're going to see how he acts before
the robot comes out and then when the
robot comes out and then after the robot
has gone away and I want you to look for
the difference before and after so here
is beforehand notice he doesn't look at
us he doesn't make eye contact is not
even facing us he's a Caillat like he
repeats what we say he's not really
engaged in the conversation and then the
robot comes out and now he's smiling
he's engaged he's trying really hard to
sound encouraging
you'll see him in a second glance over
to the woman in the brown shirt right
there that's something we hardly ever
see him do that's a behavior called
social referencing Barry does it again
and here he is afterwards he's not
facing us but he's making reasonable eye
contact he's engaged in the conversation
he's asking questions and this is with
five minutes our clinical therapist
friends like to say that we are the best
warm-up act ever this kind of changed
this kind of attentiveness system this
kind of engagement for this child is
very rare and we don't often see it and
that's what makes us excited about this
this idea that we can make a real
difference here now we've tried to say
is it the robot is it the robot itself
that really makes this difference and so
we did another study where we tried to
compare interactions with an adult with
interactions with a robot and
interactions with another piece of
technology and we did this the summer
before the first iPads came out and so a
tablet was an extremely interesting new
device nobody had really seen one before
and so we had kids come in and over the
course of the day they played three
block building games one with an adult
one with a robot the little dinosaur
plio and one on a tablet we wanted to
have a case that was social but that
they had seen before it wasn't novel
that was the adult a case that was both
social and novel the robot and something
that was novel something they never done
before but that wasn't social
and that was the tablet and we
randomized the order of this and we did
all of the good things that a scientist
should do to make sure that we don't
have any artifacts in this data and we
looked at how the kids responded in
these different conditions I'll give you
an example so here's one child with
autism who is looking at three different
interactions here he is first
interacting with an adult he's supposed
to play this game with the woman in blue
and he's not really interested in
playing with her that's typical for him
here he is playing the same game a
little while later with the dinosaur
robot he's excited he's engaged and here
he is playing with the tablet and
parents this should be an absolutely
familiar behavior for all of you he's
basically silent and when he does ask us
questions it's about the robot that he
saw a few hours ago okay so we looked at
how much did the kids talk in these
different conditions and sure enough
they talked the most when the robots
there they talked the least when the
tablet is there we expected that but we
tried to say well is it why are they
talking more when the robot is there is
it that they're just talking to the
robot and so we analyzed it to say who
are they talking to are they when
they're playing a game with a partner
how much do they talk to that partner
and it turns out they talked to the
woman in blue as much as they talked to
the robot the difference was when they
had the robot there they spent more time
talking to that other woman the woman in
the brown sweater then in any of the
other conditions the robot made them
engage more socially with another person
than they did when we had a person there
or a piece of novel technology so we
think that the robots can really do
something here we think that we have a
great way to study this but we had a
problem all of our robots were designed
to do these short little five minute or
30 minute interactions but we needed to
be able to do this over a period of
weeks and that meant being able to build
a different kind of robot one that could
change over time one that could adapt to
the child and that was a real challenge
for us you know that somebody who tells
the same joke every day the joke isn't
funny anymore the robot that does the
same thing every day it's not
interesting anymore so we started
thinking about how to build robots that
really do help kids not just kids with
autism but all kids and we were lucky
enough to get this wonderful support
from the National Science Foundation to
work with this great team of people to
think about how to build robots that can
be a long term coach that can change
about what kind of information what
kinds of lessons it's giving you as you
learn new things that can be
personalized to you that can change as
you change that can adapt to the kinds
of strengths and weaknesses and the
kinds of things that motivate you and
we've been trying to build those and
I'll show you the first set so we have
this great group of partners that we
work with and our first attempt was this
little robot we call the dragon bot and
it's about this big and it sits on the
table and the dragon bot talks to you
and we use this robot for a bunch of
different things but the one I'm going
to show you about today we've been using
the robot with first graders to teach
nutrition everything that we know about
nutrition says that the sooner you can
get people to have good habits the
easier it's going to be and so we're
targeting first graders kids who don't
get to make choices about what they eat
and we're trying to teach them something
about how to make healthy choices and so
with this robot we've had this robot in
schools both on the west coast and in
summer programs here on the East Coast
trying to teach nutrition to first
graders okay and so they go in with the
robot for about 15 minutes for each
session and we give them six sessions
over the course of two or three weeks
and through those six sessions they get
to meet the robot the robot's name is
chili and Chile has a story chili
desperately wants to win the big dragon
race and this is the first year that
chili has been old enough to race now
Chili's sister she's older and she won
the last couple of years and chili
really wants to win this year and he's
found out that if you eat the right
things you'll be faster in the race and
so the kids have a job they have to help
chili pack his lunch and decide what
chili should eat now chili eats foods
that humans eat chili doesn't eat
special dragon food and so they choose
things that they would like chili to
have for his dragon lunch
and we talked to them about the kinds of
choices that they can make should Chile
take water or juice or milk what kinds
of things should Chile be packing and
the kids find this interesting and
exciting and when we're done at the end
Chile sends them a little postcard
saying how well he did in the race and I
want to show you a couple of kids in the
way that they interact with this robot
so here's one girl who's picked out milk
for the robot and in a second you'll
hear Chile respond
and so we're asking them to make choices
we're giving them some information about
what healthier choices are but it's up
to them to make them I want you to watch
this girl's response to show you just
how engaged she is
we never get the kids to look away
during these sessions and finally again
the same girl a couple of weeks later
and so we've been in classrooms doing
this with kindergarteners and trying to
see how much we can actually do with
them now our first question was are they
still going to find the robot
interesting and after three weeks the
kids are just as happy and just as
interested in just as engaged as they
were on the first day but most
importantly the things we find them
asking about the things we find them
saying changes over that three-week
period in the beginning they give very
short Curt answers to the robot or at
best they expand a little bit on what
they were talking about and by the end
after three weeks there's sometimes
giving those short answers but they're
sometimes talking about the foods that
they ate at home or at school they're
relating the things that they've talked
about with the robot to their life and
that's exactly what we want to happen
now we've been doing this with all sorts
of different robots we have robots going
out into schools to do english language
learning for kids from homes that speak
primarily spanish and portuguese we have
robots that are going out to look at
kids with severe behavioral disorders
adolescents we have robots that are
going to be built to do to go back into
our autism classrooms and do more work
there and so we've been doing this with
a lot of different places and every
place that we look at
we see basically the same kind of thing
the robot is a fantastic motivational
tool and it's a way for us to provide
one-on-one support when we don't have
enough time in people to do that with
each child so I want to say thanks first
to a whole crowd of people that make
this work possible including a whole lot
of undergrads and some of our high
school interns many of the pieces that
you saw early on were designed by
undergraduates or by our high school
students and so the let the sort of last
thing I want to be able to say to you is
this is stuff that you can be doing this
is stuff that with a very small amount
of experience you can be doing stuff
that no one's ever done before and
that's incredibly exciting in the world
of science so if you want to find out
more our websites are up here those are
the best places to look yes we do look
for high school interns and there's
instructions on the website of how to do
that and thank you guys very much for
your attention I hope you enjoyed